five people now dead and three injured
as a result of that crash according to
police this investigation really a
complex one that's something one local
cyclist knows quite well
the i-team's vanessa murphy now joining
us live with more vanessa
brian richard straiter is a retired
metro sergeant
who headed the unit which investigates
deadly crashes he's also
a cyclist he mentioned that word of this
crash today
spread quickly as joe mentioned
throughout the cycling community in
southern nevada people
calling each other texting each other
reaching out to make sure
they are okay now straighter says he
learned his friend who was
riding in that group is okay but of
course now we know five people did not
make it
now during his time at metro straiter
investigated crashes like this one
he says nevada highway patrol will
likely inspect the truck involved to
make sure it's at the right weight the
tires inflated properly the brakes
working correctly
the roadway shut down for hours to make
sure all
evidence is collected and to even check
the road itself
for example to figure out how slippery
it may or may not have been
at the time of the collision straiter
says on a major roadway like the 95
a mistake can happen quickly behind the
wheel
you know you know 55 miles an hour
you're covering a lot of distance
and just even this the slightest
movement on your uh
steering wheel can cause you to change a
lane or drift off into the shoulder of
the lane
now in nevada when drivers are passing
cyclists
they must move into an adjacent lane to
the left when possible
or leave at least three feet between
their vehicle and the bicycle
according to the department of motor
vehicles and cyclists
must ride to the right unless they're
turning left or going
the same speed of traffic they
also have the same rights and
responsibilities
as drivers i know that a three-foot rule
is very
important to cyclists reporting live
vanessa murphy 8 news now